We've now completed our review of
data and interoperability standards.
This is an immense field, and we've
only skimmed the surface in an effort to
equip you with a working knowledge
of the areas being standardized,
the approaches and technologies being
used, and the potential benefits.
You should recognize that for
the most part health informatics
standards have been developed
within the industry and
have only recently begun to adopt
approaches such as XML and web services.
You should also appreciate
the inevitable attention
that exists between the need many feel
to create very detailed standards for
everything and
the complexity that creates.
Often this complexity gets in
the way of the real objective,
which is implementation and use of the
standards in day-to-day patient care.
And the increasing recognition of that
seems to be leading to a new willingness
to look outside of healthcare and
to adopt more facile and
easy-to-implement approaches,
such as FHIR.